this is from tjw when writing a TV spec
how far in the future should you know
your story multiple seasons yeah I would
say so I'd say you should know what the
end of its going to be you really should
what's interesting is you take a show
like Mad Men but you know that the be
the end of the show nothing's really
going to be any different the beginning
there really isn't if the first episode
of Mad Men Don Draper is a New York ad
man who's really unhappy in his marriage
and he's he's got a big hole in his soul
what's the last final scene of of Don
Draper this madman episode he's gonna go
back and be in New York admin he's a
seducer of women untroubled with his
relationship with women and he's got a
big hole in his soul right so it's not
hard to know the ending of your TV show
because it's gonna be the same as your
beginning there's there's really no
unless it's a miniseries where like true
detective we're in season 1 where rusty
and Marty actually change incredibly
because that's a movie basically
remember miniseries are long movies
you're always just gonna be in the same
place so yeah knowing the endings not
hard you're gonna be in exactly the same
places you were at the beginning Buffy
the Vampire Slayer is still slaying
vampires and still not happy about it at
the end okay Glover in Atlanta his
character however long Atlanta goes
unless he just wants to say screw you
I'm not going to do what you expect me
to his characters still gonna be bumping
along feeling like a loser at the very
end of Atlanta sneaky pete same thing
sneaky Pete's still gonna be conflicted
about having a family versus being a con
artist being alone versus being with his
family I don't care how many seasons you
have so it's not hard figuring out where
your television show is going to go
because it's going nowhere
you